Using drones from the air
and armored bulldozers on the ground.
Israel is launching
its largest military incursion
into the occupied West
Bank city of Janine in two decades.
So Israel says
the operation is focused
on counterterrorism.
Palestinians
call it a new war crime
against our defenseless people.
The Palestinian Health
Ministry says at least eight
people have been killed
with that number likely to rise.
And at least 50 others now injured
Israel says it hit terrorist
infrastructure in the densely
populated Jenin refugee camp.
The operation comes less than two weeks
after a raid
in the same area
erupted into a massive firefight,
killing at least five Palestinians.
We want to go straight
to our how to school to joins us now
live near Jerusalem.
Obviously, this is a notable escalation
Hadassah.
Can you give us a sense of this operation
both on the ground,
but also in historical terms,
given the uptick in violence
that you've covered now
for the last 18 months?
Yeah, we have been
covering this regular
sort of cycle of violence
for the past 18 months.
The Israeli military launching
these regular raids
into the occupied West Bank
after a series of a Palestinian attacks.
Targeting is really it's now
the Israeli military
saying that
they're going into the West Bank
to try to prevent militants from
from being able to later
carry out attacks.
But it just seems to be perpetuating
the cycle of violence.
And we have been reporting
it seemingly time and time again
about how everything we're seeing
is once again
reminiscent
of the days of the second intifada,
when Israeli tanks were seen
in the actual cities themselves
and in the West Bank.
But really,
today is something new
because it's been confirmed
now from an Israeli
military source
telling CNN that this is the largest
Israeli military operation
in the West Bank since 2002.
When you look at just
the full number of soldiers,
hundreds of sort of Israeli soldiers,
the fact that they were using airstrikes
from drones,
we know of at least ten airstrikes
that were being carried out in Jenin.
When you look at the bulldozers
that are tearing up streets on this,
on the streets of Jenin now.
Israeli military saying
this is being done to
to try and root out
IEDs that militants place
underneath the surface
level of the street.
But obviously, that affects
the civilians
who are living there as well.
And we are actually seeing Israeli tanks,
not in Jenin itself,
but on the outskirts
outside the city limits.
Again, these are not scenes
that we are used to seeing here,
at least not since the days
of the second intifada.
And, Paula, this is ongoing as we speak.
We are still getting reports
of firefights.
The Israeli military
saying that
they just in the last hour, 2 hours
or so, were engaged
in firefights with militants at a mosque.
They say that they discovered
some underground tunnels under them,
also being used to store weapons.
We are getting reports of potentially
even further airstrikes.
This has now been going on for or for
definitely more than 12 hours.
Think we're approaching now
16 hours of this operation.
And yet still the Israeli military
saying that it is not necessarily
a large scale operation
against the entire West Bank.
They say they are focused on Jenin
and that they want to essentially
prevent Jenin from once again
becoming what they call
a safe haven for militants.
Now, we are hearing that at least eight
Palestinians have been killed.
There have been some reports
that some of them
at least are militants,
but no militant group
has claimed them yet as their own.
We know of at least 50
who have been injured.
One Israeli
soldier has been injured as well.
But of course, for the civilians there,
I was actually just in Jenin yesterday
on the ground talking to residents
they today are saying this is something
they have never seen before
or at least have not seen in decades now.
The White House has said
that they are closely monitoring
the situation.
They did say broadly
they support
Israel's security
and its fight against terrorism.
But there is a concern
that this will spill over
into something much broader
that this will spillover
across the West Bank.
We've already heard
from the militant group Hamas.
It has called on its members,
on its cells to strike Israel.
It said, wherever it can, Paula.
Yes, certainly.
I'm glad
that you could put that
into historical perspective.
As you said,
more than two decades
in terms of this escalation.
We will continue to follow this
developing story for us.
Hadassah Gold for us.
Appreciate your update.
Time now for the exchange.
Our next guest tweets
that the Jenin refugee camp
is about one square kilometer
and about and home
to about 13,000 people.
I mean, think of that.
It's incredibly crowded.
And she says targeting this camp
from the air
and ground puts all residents at risk.
Nora is a political analyst
and a former spokesperson
for the Palestinian Authority,
and she joins me now
live from Ramallah in the West Bank.
I want to get right to what you know
about the operation
in the ground right now.
What can you tell us
about the operation itself
and what are you hearing from your
sources on the ground?
Well, I can tell you that
journalists have been struggling
link to cover the story on the ground.
They are
they've come under direct fire
themselves.
The medical crews as you reported,
have also had a lot of difficulty
accessing the refugee camp
and retrieving the injured
or tending to those who need help.
Including the elderly
and the civilians trapped
in the refugee camp
during this operation,
which is going on almost 16 hours now.
And a lot of
former colleagues who have covered
who had covered the 2002 invasion
of the refugee camp
say the atmosphere
is very reminiscent
of that bloody episode
when Israel killed
over 60 Palestinians
and basically pummeled
the refugee camp, destroyed it, leveled
many of its neighborhood
neighborhoods to the ground
also under the very similar pretenses.
You know, it's hard for us
to actually get a read of what's
going on the ground.
We have live pictures
right now of Janine.
As you can see as the sun is setting,
we still see smoke rising from there.
The Israeli government
believes that this operation
will continue for some hours
to come in terms of tactics here.
What are you hearing as well?
Sure.
It's difficult for you to get information
because, you know,
mobile Internet
coverage is spotty,
sometimes nonexistent.
We just had that update
from the Palestinian
Red Crescent saying
medical professionals
were having a hard time
getting to those injured.
I mean, give us an indication
of operationally what this will look like
if you're inside such a crowded camp
right now.
Well, let me try to visualize
this for the viewers.
Basically, a large contingent of Israeli
armored vehicles
have gotten into the refugee camp.
They've basically plowed
many of the streets.
They destroyed the water network,
cut off electricity.
So the residents
now have no electricity,
no water and nowhere to go.
And many of the buildings
have been taken over by Israeli soldiers
to be used as sniper positions.
So those who who have had the misfortune
of Israeli soldiers
taking over their home
are now trapped in those homes.
That is being used by Israeli soldiers
to shoot at Palestinian activists.
And I want to put this in perspective.
If you if you allow me
for Palestinians, these horrible scenes
and these S.O.S.
calls from paramedics
and from journalists
and from residents of the refugee camp
are part of a very of a bigger
and very violent
picture of daily life
under Israeli occupation.
The Palestinians are ruled against their
will by the Israelis.
And in order to maintain that rule,
which is
violent in its nature,
Israel conducts these campaigns
against Palestinian resistance,
which exists
because the occupation exists.
As you know,
your reporter was reporting
out of Ukraine a few moments ago
and was talking about efforts
to combat occupation there.
It's pretty much the same
when it comes to Palestinian.
I do,
fortunately,
the international reaction
is very different.
I want our reporting
says that the United States
Biden administration
is watching the situation closely,
but it continues to hold the line
saying that, look, Israel
is entitled to safeguard its security.
I also want to get to those calls
from Hamas and Islamic
Jihad to, in their words,
strike Israel
by all available means
to stop the massacre.
I mean,
how much of a tipping point
are we at here
in terms of an escalation,
especially, you know, all available means
basically as a call to action
for more violence, is it not?
Well, again, I
want to
just bring in the
Palestinian perspective here.
Being ruled against your will
by a foreign
military is violent
and it's violent every day,
even when it doesn't make the news.
The fact that Hamas and Islamic
Jihad are now calling for reaction
against the
the invasion of the refugee camp
is predictable.
There is nothing surprising about that.
Just as there was nothing
surprising about the fact
that Palestinians don't
want to be ruled by foreigners who use
unnecessary force,
who use extreme force against civilians.
Israel has killed more Palestinians
this year so far than it did
the year before,
which was already the most violent in
the past 16 or 17 years.
It has allowed for settlement expansion
that has exceeded
the total number
of settlement units built last year,
only in the past six months.
This is really government
which Israelis are protesting against
is the most violent, most extreme,
most anti-Palestinian
that we've seen
since Israel's establishment perhaps
at its core.
And its declared agenda is not just
to maintain control over the West Bank,
to annex that West Bank
and consider it part
of Israel, but also to crush
the very notion
of Palestinian freedom and statehood
so that the Palestinians
are not only under attack,
they feel that their very existence
is under attack.
So we will continue to follow
the breaking news on this story.
I want to update us that it from 50
it's now gone to at least 80 wounded.
That's the information we're getting.
We thank you for your insights on this.
As I say, we continue
to follow the breaking news
out of Israel. Appreciate it.